hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round one of the second
fight a Grand Prix tournament this year
I played in Riga Latvia it's Maxine
bachelor Grogg with the white piece
against David Navarro it's a very
exciting game we do not have a photo of
the players playing this game but that's
not Nikki's fault that's the fault of
the players which you will see while
later we do have a couple of other nice
photos so here we can check out the the
photo of the playing venue there you
have it also complements of Nikki Riga
so let's just enjoy that for a second
never at the board maxime not to be
found anywhere maybe that's him looking
at 11 but no I think that's maybe Donal
dubov yeah standing order no it's not
gooble playing against mama DRF so it's
hard to say where Maxine is if any of
you can spot him you know do help out in
the comment section so that being said
let's check out this very nice game
Maxime has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 we have c6 by navara the Carl
Kahn defense Knight to f3 with b5 and
now Knight to c3 our you're asking black
if you want to advance the pawn to d4
but you don't want to do this because
after Knight to e2 it's gonna be very
hard to defend this pawn
you can't play e5 and if you play C 5
then white will just attack the center
which with his C pawn and the white will
just have a very nice game here
Bishop to g4 this is the main move in
this position at Nevada goes for it with
h3 asking do you want to go back do you
want to capture on f3 this is the line
black plays in this variation so he will
give up the bishop pair early and now
Knight to f6 putting pressure on the e4
pawn with Bishop to e2 and now e 6
preparing to develop the dark square
bishop and then castle with castles by
maksim and now Bishop to c5 with rook to
d1 preparing d4 and even though this
position has been reached before there
is only one move that is always played
here and that's Bishop to d4 some move
that serves well you don't want to allow
white push d4 for example if you just
castle if you don't want to waste time
then d4 will be very strong for white
for example pawn captures Knight
captures Bishop back to e7 as the bishop
is attacked on c5 and now
can just trade here play Queen to g4
with the Queen and rook now guarding
this pawn here and it will be just a
very nice position for white still
having the bishop pair you know the
position basically plays itself so only
one position for black here but one move
for black here brush up to d4 and here
we have Queen to f4 now there is only
one game where Queen to f4 was played
here you can play something like d3 you
can play Queen g3 right away but Maxine
goes for Queen to f4 and it has been
played only once before in the game
Etienne back road versus Robert is El
Church in the inn last year in 2018 in
Zagreb in the tournament of peace that
was once again started after many years
of inactivity and Tim Bakker won't want
a very nice game there against the Zell
Chooch the game continued e5 same as
this game pushing the Queen back to g3
attacking the g7 pawn and here we had
castles by him by Robert Zoellick but
here he captures on d4 so Navarre plays
a new move and now Maxime has to decide
what to do here now what will you do
well obviously do you want to capture on
g7 seems like you don't want to capture
on g7 your king is already cast out here
Ruby it is coming maybe it would be
giving black a bit too much activity for
the price of one point but Maxime had
everything prepared here he played d3 so
he willingly sacrifices upon with each
chapter on d3 Bishop captures on d3 and
now again navara not sure if he had it
analyzed at home up until this point but
he played knight bt7 and now he asks
Maxime do you want to capture on g7 and
here at Maxime after thinking for a
while decided to play Knight to e2 which
is not the best idea I mean the best
idea is that actually capture the g7
phone but it's a no human would play
this because after Queen characters of
course it will be met with rook to g8
and after Queen to h6 black will
probably go Queen e7 preparing to Castle
queenside perhaps double rooks on the G
file and created an attack against the
White King but here you don't really you
don't really have a chance to do this
because white has Bishop to f5 here
very hard move to find because now if
black continues with something like
queenside castle black is lost our black
is lost because blush up to g5 and you
don't have a good way to defend the
night here you can just capture it as
this knight is pinned here so perhaps
black and on p.m. Queen King c7 but then
Knights the e4 and now the knight is
attacked three times you do not have
sufficient means of defending this
position you have to give up the
exchanged capture screen characters but
it is no compensation for basically the
only thing you have in exchange for so
much sacrifice material is the semi open
G file which is not all that much in
this position well it would seem so 9b
d7 a really really a big Bluff
bye-bye Davi navara or maybe both of
them just agreed that capturing and g7
was out of the question
I mean who would actually capture there
so continuing Knight to e2 okay you want
to capture the bishop here open up the
e-file maybe harass the black King for a
bit but here navara castles King side so
what could have been a really insane
game with a good black castling
queenside we now have castling kingside
and it's not a problem
first Bishop to f5 now of course the
rook is eyeing that Queen on d8 at some
point you want to play c3 you know
create some tactics to work in your
favor so Knights the c5 and here what do
you do it seems like the bishop is now
trapped well it's not really because
after c3 the rooks are not connected you
can play Bishop captures and then
whatever captures you will just lose the
rook on d1
so first the maxime has to connect rooks
Bishop to h6 an excellent way to connect
rooks now you're threatening checkmate
but also there's the threat of c3 so
what can Navarro do here here navara the
best idea for black here is Knights to
e6 and now you can meet c3 with Knight
to h5 just attack the Queen and after
the Queen moves and now you can capture
on g6 see capture some before and you
will play Queen g5 just on pinning and
of course White is still better but the
game continues
however navara Hill here played nice to
h5 immediately without the previous
night to e6
he attacked the Queen with Queen to g4
and here Navarro played Queen
six and it seems like okay I don't have
a problem with this if you if you play
something like c3 I can always capture a
bishop here and it's it's you know
everything works in my favor but feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find what Navarre missed in this
position as its well is it's quite
strange I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who played c3
here you should really work on your
tactics although a c3 seems like a very
nice idea it doesn't work because again
Bishop captures an f2 with check you
just grab a pawn King captures and now
Queen captures an h6
just you know I grab who grabs the
bishop there's no threat of checkmate
the Queen also now guards the knight on
e5 and white really doesn't have
anything here it's not white who's
basically lost so for those of you who
found Queen captures on h5 here then
congratulations you do not need to work
on your tactics well everyone always
needs to work on their tactics but not
as much as those who played pawn to c3
because now there's nothing to do here
never our continued Queen captures on h6
we have Queen captures on h6g chapters
on h6 and now only after all is said and
done c3 and it was in this position that
David Navarro resigned the game as there
is nothing more to do here the bishop is
trapped and well you can give it up for
whom on pawn but that's that's no
compensation at all captures captures
and it's it is unplayable I mean it's
it's a clean Bishop a white is up a
piece and that's just no way in a way to
play chess so really amazing 22:27
hundred-plus player blundering a piece
on move 16 not seen very often
especially in a classical event since
the grand prix is a classical event
unless to classical games are drawn then
we go into rapid then if the wraps are
drawn will go into blitz and in the end
Armageddon the same way we had it in the
in the mosque of grand prix that we
covered a few months ago so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it that's why
probably that's why we don't have any
nice photo of the players because the
game just ended too quickly and well
it's at some photos that you
I did see of their table either navara
was missing or Maxine was missing like
the one we said we saw of the playing
venue but you know there are a lot more
rounds for more photos to come and we're
gonna enjoy that as well so once again I
do hope you enjoyed it another more who
most likely didn't I would like to thank
Tim O'Connor Lawrence Morris Hager a
free at Jack Bancroft and Marco Morocco
loafer can moved to my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Philly
Grand Prix in in Riga Latvia of course
continuing the capablanca saga and
checking up on your suggestions thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday